you
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody the
next set of scientific talks let's kick
it off with Emanuel who is an associate
professor at Princeton but who's also
spending time at EPFL now and he's gonna
talk to us about universality and the
materials of deep learning thank you and
thank you Sam in India for the
invitation can you hear me well okay
let's see I think it's a another strong
microphone we'll see okay so this is
joint work with Colleen Sandin it was
now at MIT we started this a few years
ago now when he was a student at
Princeton we posted the first version on
archive a few months ago with about half
of the story and hopefully that's the
the the complete story here we'll post
the paper hopefully very soon okay so
deep learning has been very successful
in image specification and not just in
images that look like that meaning
classical natural images but also more
complex settings medical images or games
so the question here is how far can deep
learning go can it learn any function
which is efficiently learnable or does
it have any limitations and a good
starting point to investigate questions
like that are this kind of function
where on the first class you have images
that look like this and on the second
class these are the images so there's
nothing within the pattern of these
images the only difference is that
there's an odd number of points here and
here an even number of points so that's
simply the priority function and this
was long known to be a difficult
function for in fact the perceptron at
the book of perceptrons by Minsky and
Papert spend a lot of time on this case
and on the issues that the perception
has with it another case where they
spend a lot of time is the one on the
cover of the image which is a
connectivity so these are two shapes
that are apparent very similar the
difference is that this one is connected
there's a single
orange shape and this one has two
connected RN shape that are disconnected
among themselves so a more modern
version of this problem would be a model
like this where the function is either a
connected graph here that's another
shiny graph which is above the
connectivity threshold and this is a to
version on half the vertices where there
are no edge between them or their
communities meaning there's a few edge
among them except that I will break the
small cycles all the cycles of depths of
length up to route log n so all these
problems have the commonality I mean
those those two here and the one here
that there's no clear feature low
complexity feature that you can extract
and compose to learn the function no
matter what you try here there's not a
clear pattern that dictates the party in
fact the party is extreme if you don't
see a single of this square if you don't
know the its if it's active or not you
cannot deduce the party so that's the
topic and of course these were the
difficulties that the perceptron had in
1969 and the simple perceptron with the
computational power of 69 and this is
what the neural Nets looked like now so
this was this was apparently a neural
net training here at Microsoft Research
I got this from reddit user mat files
it's a it's a three million nodes and
ten million edges it's it looks very
nice so it's pretty far from the
perceptron and and the compositional
power of the time and I guess the
question is who can in this era of deep
learning with the size and the depths
can we learn any function that's a
boolean to simplify that can be learned
in poly time okay so I want to define
this now what do I mean by deep learning
and what do I mean by I can learn so
there's quite a few things we know about
deep learning but about neural nets
first of all for the approximation error
any function on n variables that can be
implemented in poly time can also be
expressed by our neural net of poly size
okay so that's just express ability but
we also know that Police's neural net
can be learned with a sample complexity
which is polynomial but that Ivor is
with erm and this is a VC bound and
unfortunately erm is np-hard here so the
main question in this theoretical
computer science free a framing of the
problem is a boy size neural nets with
SGD in pulley steps can this be the
ultimate learning paradigm using the
terminology of the book of Bend
evidential Shalev Schwartz in fact I
refer to that book II to to all the
references beyond these claims so so
that's the question can SG d be the
alternative to erm that makes it
efficient and universal so of course
there's the first issue to worry about
is SGD needs an initialization of the
weights and because of the first point
here because any neural Nets of size
polynomial can express any function that
we care about then we could always cheat
and preset the weights to be if you are
given a specific target function to
compute that specific function and then
in zero step SGD we already learn the
function so it doesn't make sense to ask
the prime like this but we can ask the
question in two ways either you are
given a specific target function like
the parity on the entire set and now
you're no longer allowed to have degree
of freedom on the initialization but you
want to show that if with a random
initialization of your net you would
still learn the function in poly step
yeah that's the first way to ask the
question or we will not force ourselves
to rest do not restrict ourself to
random initialization we will leave the
grier freedom for that but now we know
you have a specific target function in
mind we have a set of possible functions
that's the classical statistical
learning framework or here I will not
really work with a set of function but
with a distribution on function so
basically you have a random function
that you don't know which one Nature has
drawn and now you can choose your
initialization the way you want but you
of course you can't cheat anymore
because you don't know which one it has
to be agnostic to the chosen function so
the second formulation for example in
the case of parties could be the
following you now going to take the
parties so the x i's are plus minus one
so this is exactly computing the sign of
the vector but you only restrict
yourself to a support S which is
uniformly drawn
okay so nature does that you don't know
what s is and you want to learn what s
it is so if you fail a two in this
framework for example of parities then
in particular if you fail for no matter
how you choose your initialization you
will also fail for a random
initialization in particular and because
a function the model like this one has
symmetry if of my ID weight on my neural
nets it doesn't matter which function
which party function has been was the
one selected by nature as long as it's a
typical one so if you fail at two in a
case like priorities you will also fail
Oh at one for a specific for a typical
priority function okay so in a sense if
you have a negative result for two it
implies in case of models like this sort
of symmetry it implies a negative result
for one okay so now I still have to tell
you what does it mean to learn can learn
so the setup we will have in this talk
is the following we restrict ourselves
to boolean vectors for the data domain
so black and white images and binary
labels so two classes only px is a
distribution on the input and p f is a
distribution on the set of function from
x to y there's a notation to simplify
notation also we will assume that the
classes are balanced so roughly the same
number of of class one and class two so
that's the property that you put a label
one when you sample an input and an F
independently and now we can define what
learning means and this is the
definition I will use we call it weak
learning so you can wit learn a
distribution a pair of distribution for
the data and the function in T's in T
time steps if when nature picks a random
function according to that PF you can
query t x in a reco that uses the F
which Nature has picked in some way and
the distribution so for SGD is the usual
framework you see a data point label
from px and sorry you see a data point
sample from px and a label from the true
function f and after this T time step of
training you will output some estimator
F at of T and your hope is that this is
why it's called weak learning that the
property that you get the right label
with your estimator this is the right
label on a new fresh
at NC plus one should be better than
half okay half plus a constant epsilon
that's Omega and n here the dimension of
the input is this n here okay so this if
you fail at that you fail for example at
back learning which is asking for more
so in a sense that's perhaps the the
first non-trivial concept of learning
like it's hard to come up with something
that is weaker this is a asking for
guessing right so that's the recovery
the labeling has to be right for a
typical F that's like expectation over F
as opposed to for all F in your supports
okay so the neural nets that we will
work with are pretty generic ones so
weighted directed graph with a
collection of special input vertices at
the roots and plus one because an input
and the constant and then it's no
particular restriction directed acyclic
with weights and on the on the black
vertices you have some non-linearity
that could be LTS Sigma it or I will
specify if we need something particular
okay is that is there anything about the
set up so okay so the results I'll start
with a negative result a gradient
descent cannot learn efficiently
function distributions having low cross
predictability so CP stands for cross
predictability and this is the
definition it depends on the two
parameter of our problem the input the
distribution of the data in on the
functions and something very simple is
simply the correlation between two
random function there are sample under
PF the expected correlation okay so for
example if you have a prior PF which is
very good like it's very spiked around a
specific function so if you essentially
knew in advance what the function was
then the cross product ability would be
one because f and f prime would be the
same with high probability so in the
extreme where your PF is deterministic
is a delta then the the largest value
for CP is 1 if you have completely
random functions then your cross product
ability would be to do the minus n if
you have complete junk function
and the other case which is interesting
is that if you have the parity function
that we have in the second slide then
this will have a cross predictability
that is also 2 to the minus n lakh
random function so these are all very
classic measures and this is a the first
notion that comes so what does it mean
to see low CP it means that the DK is
going to be faster than any polynomial
so n to the minus that's what we need
for the Cross predictability so if you
have this if your if your P xpf have
this property of having a very weak
correlation typically then you cannot
learn and cannot learn means the
following that if you have any
polynomial size neural network any
initialization doesn't matter where it
is you train it we spotted it time steps
you have a poly learning rate so that
means I'm theory dealer Enoch will even
be decaying but if you wanted to play
with large learning rate it could not be
larger than point ml numbers poly range
and poly noise that's the the range of
values for the weights and the noise
that you add on those weights so in a
sense that's the the SNR their precision
versus magnitude of the weights the both
have to be polynomial and if you have
this any of these if you have all this
restriction together then you will not
be able to learn under this low cross
spread yes you add on your gradients you
add noise so when you compute your
expected gradient you add some noise and
you need to add that noise if you don't
add that noise this result fails so this
polynomial you need to at least have a
noise which is polynomial it's all of
Moore's except the last one yeah they
all at most accepted as I mean yes yeah
you wouldn't want a result that says a I
mean it would not make sense the other
way around but it's true that it's I
should mention I should specify you need
at least a poly noise if you have an
expert if you have zero noise or if you
have exponentially low noise so for
exponentially though you can still do it
with parities for example because
parities have an X
low crossbred but in general if you just
if your crossbred is not necessarily
exponentially low but it's just like
this then you would need a poly noise
what do you mean by that you mean yeah
yeah I mean that's the that's the
defiance of the noise poly RIT is a
learning rate that you when you multiply
your gradient as to be polynomially or
the range the range is the weights they
take value in interval minus a a and if
you are below that interval minus a is
you flatten it to you keep it there it's
like your overall flow range
you wouldn't so it this could be large
an a lower end to the thousand but it
couldn't be exponential so so these
conditions yeah rate you'll not be able
to get to range it's bigger than
foldable anyway not because you you're
even initialization you can choose what
you want right yeah then you can remove
if you do plus minus one in the plasma
is one rate yeah right so I can discuss
perhaps later on at the end that in fact
these are necessary some extent if you
break any of this condition if you
remove the range or the noise of the
probably rate we no longer have a result
like that and and for some reason so I
have to say a few things about no not
just for our proof to work we believe we
don't have come to example we believe
they're necessary actually yeah we have
okay I'll tell you more at the end I
think they are in fact unnecessary and I
think we could potentially find counter
example for each for removing each so
let me say a few words about papers here
that are important the first one is that
this is pretty similar to the
statistical dimension in fact it's
reverse proportional to the statistical
dimension the difference between the SQ
framework and this framework well of
course
GD is a special case of a statistical
query
if you're not familiar with this whole
query there with me or skip this it's
it's very similar except the three
differences are a we look about typical
functions not a class of functions and
we want to do well for any function in
that set so there's the typical ad on
the function B we do big learning we
just want to beat half as opposed to
getting a probability of success which
is one and C we have statistical noise
ins instead of adversarial noise but
this delay that delay the third one is
the least meaningful differences the
first two are a bit more important so
and there's a student who came this
summer and DB FL and we're writing a
note about the difference between the SQ
framework and this framework of the week
learning here and why this is an average
case version also another important
paper and I'll take the question is that
disappear there's a paper by a sheriff's
watch Shamir and Shama that don't
exactly establish a negative result for
learning but they show that the gradient
in the case of parities concentrates and
this gives strong evidence and in fact
you can alternate parities yes yeah so
it's if any loss function that is allow
you to define a gradient that as a
smooth or even like a gradient which is
well-defined
right okay so the corollary of this is
the following is that gradient descent
cannot efficiently can learn efficiently
monomials of degree K so monomials are
so x1 times x2 times x3 and you have
caterham so it can learn such functions
if and only if so it's a
characterization so learning efficiently
is under this hypothesis K is finite so
you can only learn finite degree
monomials so this is in analogy with
what we expect for let's say this
problem of connectivity that I gave you
with the erdos-renyi and the two
stochastic block model if you break all
those cycles are non constant up to rule
again then typically we expect that you
can not distinguish between the two
models because in fact this is not going
to be calling on this is going to :
point no meal to the of higher degree
than constant okay so that's the story
for gradient descent and this is of
course for the population gradient so
for long what we try to do was to obtain
the same result for SGD instead of Gd
and we kept bumping into issues with the
fact that we couldn't get as a clean set
of assumptions just polynomial things we
had to add more constraints and more
bounds and more restrictions we had a
result that if you only change a few
weights per times that for example for
coordinate descent then we get the same
result
Corian decent conductor under low CP but
we couldn't get the same result for SGD
and eventually we found out why we
couldn't get the same result for sgt and
it's simply because we had the statement
wrong as you they can learn in fact
efficiently any efficient in your noble
distribution so you don't have this this
issue with SGD that you have with GD so
so essentially as TD is in fact
universal and to clarify so efficiently
learner learnable distribution means any
P xpf that can be learned by some
algorithm in poly time with poly samples
you mean I didn't know it GD was less
noise no no architecture as we didn't
boys I need your net that has poly size
any architecture something is trying to
codify I mean obviously I cannot pick
any it's not the case that for any
policy size new on that sgpa will learn
no there exists of course it's a now it
says it's the positive result so there
exists a poly sized neural net which is
of Ponemah size there exists a poet time
initialization so that is agnostic to
the function and to the dozen new the
data that takes 40 time to be
initialized and so that if you run a CD
with poly steps with poly rate and with
poly range
and despite the fact that you ads
Paulino is on top to the gradients
now it's takest equation descent so it's
not expectation but it's a random
gradient then you will learn the
function weekly learning the way it's
defined so that's that's seem surprising
because SGD in a sense is the version
that we cannot implement when we cannot
implement Radian because we don't have
the full access to the population but it
turns out that I'll try to give a little
bit of insight that having this gradient
which has potentially larger movement
because it's not averaged over all the
data give you some extra freedom and
that allows us in fact to learn a
distribution nono so there is a either
you do gradient descent
right after your loss
let's say this is your estimator it is a
true label and you do your this is your
expected gradient that's for a Gd and
then you add noise here the adding noise
here is just because we cannot work with
infinite precision so the adding now is
a way to say that we will have some
precision in how much we can record our
data that's Gd yet as it is just you
have this random sample yeah isn't
biased but it has much more randomness
right in with yeah that's not what we
like about the city the fact it has
bigger violence makes it that in cases
that are hard cases like parties it has
more movements than this where this is
not going to be to be curated too much
with the party function so this is going
to be what is useful yes so you are
probably missing something because
charities are learning bull right got an
animation right but so what are we
missing here as GD no even with you even
miss Polly noise and precision
no no what you're missing is two things
first of all you're thinking of part
learning parties with noise which is a
different model where you have noise on
the label here is nice on the gradient
is about the precision of your
implementation do you think you can you
can learn parities in some customization
SGD right that's a surprise because ice
q SQ algorithm cannot do it right so
also two things a the learning party
with noise is noise on the labeled B if
you add polynomial that's the noise has
to be at most here has to be at most
polynomial now because it's a positive
result if you add that much these are
different noise models but
you just do a hand wavey analogy and if
you add noise which is that small it
still is pretty small noise then you
would still be able to learn parties in
the model of SWE with Gaussian
elimination gas animation is still
robust to that amount of noise however a
skew algorithm would break down for
parties even with that amount of noise
so that's the the corollary so std can
learn efficiently parties while the
perceptron GDRs burgers and cannot see
so with your definition of addition in
Luna be yeah see you're saying by some
polygon algorithm right but this is a
distributional statement so what is that
right because it's against PF thank
typically I think of like an organism on
incidence but here are you saying oh boy
um so do you see the definition for
learning it's it's this one here so
you're given a px distribution on a data
and a PF on the functions and now you
define learning it's like PAC except
that we ask for weaker with poor man so
it's for that class of px that class of
PF you have some algorithm so think of
parties priority you have the uniform
distribution on the inputs here and the
PF is a random party function so that
you can do with this with this with
learning easily with building a basis
doing a gassin elimination or inverting
the system and then you will get not
only half in the case of parties but you
can go all the way up to one yeah it's
it you will see it will probably be
disappointing it's an emulation argument
it's an emulation argument we will
reproduce gas elimination with STD for
example for collectivity so okay
coactive it is a longer story because I
haven't given you a class of function I
would like for parity is that we have an
obvious class and then we know for
connectivity you first have to be the
class of functions just to tell you that
I'll probably burn all my time so I only
can
yes dimension is volumes right so that's
what I said
that's why I said before so with the SQ
framework there's three differences the
first one is that you don't care about
the typical function f but you care
about the class of function and you are
worst case on that class of function
then there is that here we care about
weak learning we just want to be the
epsilon look at the paper maybe I don't
know this one but essentially what is
true is that you would get you would
also get a negative result for sq in as
I said this is similar flavor as s Q
side different setting and and I'll send
you this note if you wanna see
differences maybe we miss that reference
but the the constitutive fitting is the
same with sq or with this is not exactly
the same setting the one we knew but the
the flavor is the same if you have a
statistical dimension which is
exponentially which is exponential then
you are doomed likewise here if you have
a cross / activity which is exponential
lido then you also don't see so
interesting my okay I'll check thank you
I interesting I met currents himself on
Thursday I tell him this result and he
said that was amazing in here nobody so
so maybe he forgot his own paper maybe
forgot his own people yeah okay other
questions
okay so I'll tell you a bit about this
this this result but first the CP how it
emerges the CP okay so the the plan is
the following
oh time wise I'm three minutes is five
ways okay so this is a gradient descent
with the expected gradient and plus the
noise so that's where the noise is right
and the substrate subscript H here is a
placeholder for a four star if it's F it
means your training region descent with
the true data that uses DF which is the
data with the right function f and if
you see star instead of edge then is the
junk data which takes a random label on
the data so the proof strategy is that
we will show that the output of the
algorithm after horizon which is not too
large which is polynomial when you train
on the true data or the junk data is
indistinguishable does a total version
attends to zero and then by a total
version bound like this this means that
the property that you get right with the
true data when you run this on the true
data is upper bounded by when you change
the model here when you take the star
model which is drunk which by
construction will have a property of
half of guessing right because you train
on junk data and here of course you have
to put the total version distance
between the measure so QF is a measure
of WF and Q star of W star okay and
what's important here is that this is
the expected expectation over F because
we care about this week learning about
this typical case so then the first step
here is just a subadditivity argument we
want to argue that the total version
distance when you run these two
algorithm on the true and on the fake
data for t time step this is sub
additive this is less than T times the
distance you get in one time step this
is essentially very direct it uses the
data processing inequality and the
triangular inequality and to run an
induction okay so then you do Pinsker
inequality so we are here between the
total ration distance of the QF and Q
star
we have Gaussian noise so we can upper
bound it by the root of the KL
divergence between the two measures and
with Gaussian noise this becomes simply
the means that are subtracting in that
two norm okay so this is now a bit more
intuitive what we care about we care
about the expected gradient under the
true data and the junk data
how far can they be to each other and
for parties of course you can see how
this is going to be an issue because
parties is pretty close to two random
data but now we have to make this formal
so here from here to here I simply
isolate this l2 norm is over all edges
of our neural nets so we're just going
to pick one specific edge I call E and
we want to upper bound this a to norm
between the F gradient E and gradient
under true and junk data and I just
changed the measure this is a raid on
nickel in there there it even and if you
here do the cauchy-schwarz inequality
which is what we want to use eventually
the problem is that if you apply so this
is an inner product between this term
and this term if you do cauchy-schwarz
then this guy as actually norm which is
simply one it square is simply one so
you lose all the information about F so
that doesn't get you anywhere what you
would like to do is bring the
averageness over F the typicality over F
over this term here that would be much
better the problem is that you can't
bring the EF inside because we have a
square here so it's not a linear
operator so we're just gonna create
linearity as the classical trick we're
just going to lift things so we write
things instead of a square inner product
between those two thing here it becomes
with no square inner product between the
tensor to of each of these functions and
now I can bring the expectation of F
over this term and now I'm going to use
Cauchy Schwarz and so putting back the
pieces together here I get the
expectation of the gradient square does
the first term in Cauchy Schwarz I
unfold the tensor and here I just write
this theorem the expectation of this one
tensor to I write it with okay that's
just a fancy name replica for saying
that we take two iid copy of a random
variable so it's just here this is just
doing me
if x1 x2 are IID okay now you can see
that DF by DX this is something which is
a very simple because it's the true data
by the fake data so they both have the
same px for the input so this is a
measure a distribution on x and y on the
data in the label they are the same PX
that simplify and one has the true
measure in the label and the other one
as always 1/2 so this quantity here you
can see that it's simply checking it's
going to be either 1 or minus 1 whether
the label is right or wrong and this is
what the cross spread measures so with
some messaging and putting the pieces
together this is exactly the bound so
the bound looks like this the generation
error well actually here it's written
for the success error now the
Germanization so the the success the
property of getting the right label when
you train the after T time step on the
true data it's a pro bounded by 1/2 plus
3 times 1 over the noise that you add on
the gradients this gf which refers to
junk flow it's how much gradient can you
accumulate when you run your neural net
on junk data ok so you have some neural
net with some initialization could be
random you train it on junk data this
will generate some gradients at each
time step with some learning rates and
this is like the intrinsic momentum that
pure randomness gives you and this gives
you the first term here and then the
second is the crossbred you can slightly
improve the 1/4 here but it's not
important so that that's where you see
what happens if this trend flow is
polynomial like it is when you put the
restriction that I had in the theorem
then if the if the one over Sigma cannot
fight the cross spread then you can
drive this bound to 0 and then you get
something that tends to have so that's
the the proof technique so I don't have
time so I'll skip the emulation argument
and stop here
[Applause]
yes so well exactly
William young who fail if you look at
unavailable function such as the Qaddafi
Kazuyoshi people do low number it's
fatal it fit directly because we need to
have some function and can learn and to
emulate that function I know you talk
about the negative yeah that's for the
negative yeah yeah yeah yeah next up we
have Margie who will tell us about
demystifying generalization and early
stopping in neural networks Mahdi is an
assistant professor at university of
southern california thank you for the
invitation to be here
can everybody hear me good ok cool so
before I start this is joint work with
Tommy Doyle mark is a colleague at UC
Riverside and our students Alan and Ming
Chen salon is actually in the audience
so so the motivation we've heard the
story multiple times today so it's the
overcome a situation without overfitting
just to recap quickly we have more
parameters and training data and now the
question is like if we expect something
like this to happen because we're
overfitting but everything seems to be
perfect so the challenges are one has to
do with kind of optimization which is
why can your owner
first fit despite a non convexity and
then why can they predict and so that we
just remind you of some of their
experiments that that kind of
demonstrators and Peter showed this
earlier so here one a simple experiment
is like you you have your training
labels and you just corrupt a fraction
of those training their books so you
take like at zero you change it to eight
you do this randomly and as you change
the fraction of the amount of label
corruption the fraction of labels you
corrupt you you look at the accuracy so
I'm depicting free accuracies here and
it becomes clear why in a moment so
first of all you see that the trained
accuracy is perfect so neural networks
can fit even with these corrupt
corruptions if you look at the test
accuracy you know it's not great but but
it's actually pretty high it's
surprisingly it's better than random
guess and this is actually what Peter
discussed this morning why I can even
overfitting in this model why can you
still get non-trivial non-trivial test
accuracy and finally the orange cap I'm
demonstrating here is like now I'm
measuring accuracy with the ground with
respect to the ground truth labels and
that obviously should be bad right
because you know with respect to the
ground truth tables you should not be
doing anything nice so now I'm going to
maybe a little bit of a more surprising
experiment I'll just repeat the same
experiment but now stop there okay so so
now things change quite dramatically so
the chain accuracy goes consistently
down so it's not good because we're not
overfitting to the train data anymore
but what is perhaps more surprising is
that if you look at the test accuracy is
pretty good and in fact the Train
accuracy with respect to the ground
truth labels is consistently very high
and in fact up to a large fraction is
exactly 100 percent so meaning I only
fed the corrupted data in my neural
networks but if I stopped early I
actually get the true labels out okay so
so that that is the surprising part so
these are kind of the experiments you
want to try to explain a little bit
okay so and really what I'm kind of very
interested in we don't necessarily get
to this picture yet but it's really to
understand how the train and test
accuracy is evolved across time as
you're iterating we are gradient descent
so so I'll talk about like kind of free
related stories the first one is like
optimization then generalization if
there's time I'll also talk about why
that early stopping really helps here so
the optimization result is pretty
straightforward so I'm just going to
focus on a body hidden layer model and
in a regression setting so I have the
dimensional features I pass it through
non-linearity K hidden nodes and then I
actor gate
and I'm just picking at a simple
regression model so this is not
classification so I just fit like a nice
squares model like this so and here is
kind of the theorem I start from a
random initialization we run gradient
descent so the the result here is like
if the data points are distinct and you
use like a smooth activation let's say
the soft cost activation and your model
is over parameterize in a sense that the
size of the training data is less than
twice the width of the network and then
if you initialize at random you actually
get zero training your with high
probability in the sense that your error
goes down to at a geometric rate okay so
that is that is the result we currently
have and we think that we can actually
improve this further but this is not
completely said yet which is like if we
also assume that if you aggregate your
training the input training data as rows
of a matrix if this matrix has full
column rank then you could actually do
this with training the data less than
twice the number of parameters so there
there has been a lot of interesting
results recently in this space including
some of our own the difference is that
those results usually require the bit to
grope her anomaly with that and they
also have this requirement on some sort
of minimum eigen value of some matrix
right but the D here is the constant is
2 right so there is no dependence on
quantity so that that is this I have to
say the this you should not view it as a
necessarily a good result this is more
of an existential result and I think a
lot of people already mentioned this
this is just saying okay gradient isn't
can fit everything but it doesn't mean
that this is the right learning regime
so this is very much in the lazy
training regime in some sense but but
but the point is that you you can take
this argument to the very limit of
training data being on the order of
number of parameters if you want yeah in
this result I don't know in reality what
the constant should be for or is very
much important this one again this one
is still almost half of this one there
is a caveat that's why there is a star
but do you think if the data points are
distinct and this is full rank this
whole so that the one that I'm you know
this one that you should look at that
for now yeah yeah but the point is like
we were just looking at a gradient
descent again all of the results are
already in the end to the four kind of
ratio but I'm even surprised by the end
of two I mean what's trivial is KBN next
one time in yeah yeah yeah so this is
war still right like because in Keylong
doesn't know end over - OH - it did I
put the two two and nine yeah sorry it's
2 n yeah alright I think I put the two
on the right side yeah k is the BIP of
the night
yeah so that's the kind of this really
what we're hoping is like the amount of
over parameters I shall forget with the
two correctly here oh and this should
also be on the wrong side but we believe
you can show if the parameter is bigger
than twice the size of the training data
you over paralyzed by a factor of 2 then
then you're fine but this resort still
has an Asterix
for that state so again but this is very
much doesn't say that you you you you
just find a global Optima but it's
useful or not we have to still see so
what about generalization and so we have
some theory for inhalation you can tell
me if this is useful or not but
basically in this case we look at a
classification model so it's a
multi-class classification model so I'm
going to assume the output dimension is
in capital K and so the labels are one
hard encoded so so that's the sitting
but I'm still going to fit this using a
least squares model so basically the the
input dimension is the hidden mutant
knows it's little K and then out this
capital K and I just fitted this course
model so obviously I can aggregate all
of my data points and just build a very
large nonlinear least squares problem
that's what we do and we just run
gradient descent on this and I just want
to point out that gradient descent here
takes a very particular form which is
kind of the Jacobian of this nonlinear
mapping times like a residual oh and I
should have mentioned that in this
resort we fixed output there and we just
chain over the input layer so so here to
do the actual final prediction we just
look at the closest you know class to to
to our model right so we pass it for
assault max
pick the maximum right that's how we do
classification and with this D square
setting so we're now using her seem to
be the key observation that we think
might help explain some aspects of
generalization is that if you look at
this Jacobian of neural networks they
seem to have some sort of particular
eigen structure and here we're looking
at you know part of the basically the C
410 we look at only three classes we
actually now have results on a full C
for ten but you know it's not completely
ready so that's why I'm not showing it
now but basically if you look at the
histogram of this Jacobian the eigen
values of the Jacobian better are the
initialization
after after a lot of training what you
observe is that well there is a lot of
large there's a lot of small singular
values and there's a few that really pop
out so there are a few large eigenvalues
and the rest are pretty small so it kind
of seems like the Jacobian has some form
of low rank structure again not exactly
low rank just in the sense that there is
some eigenvalue that are really large
the rest are pretty small okay so so
this motivates us to think about this
Jacobian structure in our resource so as
a reminder gradient is like Jacobian
times this residual so I'm given that it
has this particular structure we if this
kind of motivates the following
definitions where we basically pick a
cut-off level for our eigenvalues things
above some cutoff level we call it like
the information space the rest is kind
of nuisance or noise space so that's
that's kind of good but here alpha is a
pre free parameter where our resources
for any alpha and you can pick the right
one you have a good result so here is
kind of our Furies we fix out who they
are like this we initialize W at random
so the JV pick is kind of the ji the
initialization this is related to this
kernel regime then our resources that if
you pick alpha proportional square root
of n and well you can think of alpha bar
like a constant if the the BIP of the
network is proportional to 1 over alpha
bar to the power 8 then the MIS
classification error you get is less
than how correlated the the labels are
with the small eigen vectors of this
Jacobian over square root of N and then
there is other terms which would be
negligible so essentially this is always
saying like if the labels are correlated
with a small eigen directions then you
know that they're small so so again the
the kind of story we want to show is
really like in the large eigen
directions learning is kind of fast you
also change very quickly
you you generalize easily but if you
move toward like the small eigen
directions you might pick up some
nuisance or noise or things of that sort
this these results also so so roughly
the story is that if your data set is
structured in the sense of the Jacobian
having this particular structure even
with constant width neural networks in
you you can actually generalize and so
on so I should mention that this in a
special case of capital K the number of
classes being one and if you pick alpha
very small it recovers a result by
Sanjeev ro and his group except that we
required this bit basically the doji saw
say that if the if the network width is
bigger than n to the eighth then you're
miss classification error is no worse
than external problem using the kernel
at initialization and so we can recover
that this order the special case with n
to the 4 but here the key idea is that
actually because this Jacobian is low
rank or approximately low rank and you
don't need to fix the entire spectrum
but only like really the top portions
are enough and you can get a very much
smaller bit so that's kind of a in
Croatian so orido's also holds if you
start from a deterministic
initialization instead of a random one
the only difference here is that it's
not the label that matters but the
initial residual so this one is perhaps
useful because you know sometimes you
don't initialize at random so maybe you
pre train your network using some other
model and then you apply this so it
could potentially apply in this transfer
learning models and the second reason
maybe this is interesting I think a lot
of speakers already touched on this and
the Nazi perhaps will do also is that
this if you have it for a fixed kind of
initialization this could apply for
different iterations so our results
would say okay if even if the initial
labels are not correlated if at some
future point it becomes better if the
correlation becomes better your
generation might improve and so so the
the
the rough picture is like you know maybe
you don't use the kernel which is like
it's Chekhovian jacobian to transfer
that initialization but you can think of
this as kind of a kernel learning
problem where the kernel keeps getting
updated so if at some point this channel
becomes more suited to your data then
the organization result would be better
of course you're not proving that that
channel becomes better that's that's
kind of the open part but it kind of
gets to this idea of adaptation the wish
is like you know just the kernel at
initialization may not be good enough
this kind of daisy chaining idea and
maybe this channel is becoming better so
that's kind of related we're not proving
that this kernel becomes further but if
it does or resolve for that file so just
to show a clear example of what our
resource kind of say this assume we have
like a mixture of Gaussian model we have
K classes each class contains maybe see
clusters so if you have mixtures of
gaussians so in this case you can kind
of specify everything I said so for
example you can check that the Jacobian
is the proximity of R and K squared
times C and if the network is this wide
you you get it kind of like a generation
error that looks like this the miss
classification error and as you can see
the number of parameters of your network
does not appear here right it's only
depends on the number of classes and the
the number of clusters per class over N
doesn't matter how how wide you make
things right
so that that's kind of the result and I
just want to mention even in this
special case you can see why going to do
rank structures are important because of
you you let the noise go to zero if you
look at the previous results the width
that that is required kind of blows up
because they depend on a minimum eigen
value of this kind of Jacobian stuff so
let me also demonstrate that why maybe
this is not too far off even for deep
neural networks that something like this
might be true so here so we're again
looking at a free class it's like free
classes in C for 10 and and so we the
top eigenvectors we look at is like the
top 50
what here I'm demonstrating is like the
residual so that's the residual is like
green the residual projected in the stop
fire 50 dimensions of the Jacobian and
then the remaining part you can see that
actually the residual on the top IBM
vectors goes down very fairly quickly on
the other directions goes down very
slowly and so this is consistent if the
picture we want which is like learning
is fast it both in terms of chain and
test on these top directions but it's
slow on the remaining and and this is
kind of the quantity that appeared in
our results how correlated is Y with
respect to the top idea vectors or with
respect to the small ones so this is
what I want to point out is like as we
iterate so at the beginning the
correlation is high but but if you
iterate the correlation becomes better
which goes back to this adaptation idea
which is the labels become much more
correlated after training with the top
eigenvectors of the Jacobian so did this
seems to be somewhat consistent if you
use atom instead of like an STD somehow
this adaptation becomes even better at
least in our example it goes all the way
to 99% but again this is not something
we can explain we're just saying that
you know this might be interesting so
these are similar resource if you add
label corruption you can see like this
decomposition can help explain why like
this dip in a generation error happens
and and finally just to see that this
quantity that appears in our translation
result is somewhat correlated with what
you see in terms of tester so here we're
varying the amount of level corruption
this is the quantity that appears in our
upper bound and this is the actual
tester and you can see that they do
somewhat grow in tandem of each other
yes that's it
so that's the tester that's going back
yeah so the rough ER fury gives you that
this decomposition that on the top idea
in vector Z you know it goes down
quickly and then on the small ones I
said that sometimes you may pick up
noise if you have
corruption that's clearly what happens
it closed down but it goes up again if
you eat it and so now if you add these
together that that's what they carry
good so that that's kind of the so Wow
maybe in two minutes I'll just discuss
what our early stopping these are this
is still very preliminary but so it's
about this experiment which is why is it
that if I stop early suddenly I can
correct all the corruptions in my
training data and and so here we assume
like a very simplistic model so so think
of it again as kind of a mixture of
Gaussian kind of model for the input
data so we are similar multiple classes
but each class consists of different
clusters so there are overall L clusters
and capital K classes so again we look
at so now I take you to my clean data
according to this cluster model I take a
rough raw fraction of it and I just
corrupted in the sense that I replace it
with some other arbitrary label so
that's the kind of setting this is the
corrupted data I have so again we fill
these squares and be a gradient descent
and we just find the closest one to our
model so our resources that as long as
the corruption level is less than a
constant here in this case 1 over 16 and
the network is sufficiently over
parametrize in terms of the number of
total clusters then if you stop
proportional to this quantity then the
closest label to your model is actually
the ground truth label so so meaning
like I started with like those
uncorrupted data I corrupted a fraction
of them you actually get the true ground
truth tables so you perfectly recover
the correct labels so that that was our
theory for that and here the key
intuition is actually twofold one is
again this idea of the Jacobian being
low rank and the second one is that this
Jacobian matrix if you look at the top I
end elections and they're very diffused
and and so as a result if you look at
how but then you're updating using
gradient descent you get Jacobian times
the residual
so what happens is you can think of the
residual as kind of the residual with
respect to the corrupted labels as being
residual with respect to the true
they're both and the corruption because
I only corrupt you know a fraction of
the labels this this this corruption is
sparse and so when I'm hitting the
jacobian if the residual the the true
labels the residual with respect to the
true labels falls on the top I can
values and grows down quickly to zero
whereas basically the corruption falls
on a small area my use and it only you
can fit it only after many many
iterations right in the first few
iterations because it's almost in a null
space you won't even see it and this is
why if you stop early is that if you
never saw the corruptions because
they're kind of the null space so that's
kind of rough today intuition and yeah
so let me conclude there so I talked
about fear is all one is like when can
you get like global optimality maybe
some ideas about generalization based on
how correlated your labels are Biff the
eigen structure of the Jacobian and
finally I discussed this talk and this
result about at least talking and so let
me stop there so that's kind of so we
only showed it in this cluster model
right oh so I'm going the wrong way so
it's a concrete example we don't know
why they have exactly the rank yeah it's
all predicated on the fact that they do
the only that you can actually formally
show it for this mixture of Gaussian
model you can you can show that
everything it checks out but if if if
the it has this eigen drop we can fool
results about it but numerically that's
what we observe I see and you regard
this to hope for the entirety of so this
all results are both basically if at
some point during training this happens
then you're good
matrix also I think they're actually
pretty closely related if you look at
the audience structure of the Hessian
it's actually one term trust Jacobian
Jacobean transport so I think actually
the the the Jacobian Jacobian transpose
I think is the dominant part of the
Hessian so so maybe that that that's why
I think they're interrelated auras are
based on a Jacobian but I bet like
hassium was he as good final top of the
afternoon is not Easter bro not E is a
professor at ETH Chicago and he's gonna
tell us about the geometry of
optimization and learning okay thanks
thanks for sticking around so I'm gonna
initially plan on giving a more maybe
higher level view about the relationship
between optimization and geometry and
how that effects that plays the key role
in in deep learning but I saw that
actually I think many of you have
already heard some version of that talk
and that ordered we also many of these
ideas were mentioned before so I'm gonna
be trying to mostly talk about some more
specific aspects but since some of you
might not remember the talk what we're
gonna do first is get it you remember
these old TV shows the beginning there
was like last time when you know the
recap of the last few chapters and
they're really really fast then you
can't really understand what's going on
there but if you saw it before then
maybe I'll jog your mind and if you
haven't seen it before I'll be super
impressed if you'll be able to
understand but at least will be an
advertisement and you can go see the
rerun so the advantage is now all these
shows are recorded and you can easily
find reruns of me giving a slower-paced
more you know understandable version of
this talk so you should say that just
this is joint work with a bunch of
people the part of and mostly
Jason Surya and Daniel and a bunch of
other people okay so but this time at
this point I don't have to I mean you or
C so this before I don't have to tell
you that something is initially maybe
strange is going on in in deep learning
that as we increase this the size of the
model we're actually instead of
overfitting we're actually generalizing
better and better and better and what's
going on here this is surprising for two
reasons one is the complexity is
increasing but we're actually somehow
improving generalization in the second
is even if we just look at a fixed size
model we're getting a very good test
error by just minimizing the the
training objective but they're actually
many other ways of minimizing the
training objectives so all these points
here are global minimum of the training
objective the general is horribly okay
so why is it that the global minima that
we find actually generalizes well and
the others don't and Peter already
alluded to to this several decades ago
and saying well what what's important is
not really the number of units what's
important is some control over there
norm or size or magnitude and in fact if
we put here some measure of norm then we
see that these global minima of the
training objectives that have high norm
don't generalize well and maybe this one
generalizes well because it has small
norm but this begs the following
question one is what is this norm I put
here the path norm but it's not the
right one what is the real measure that
the complexity measure we're minimizing
here the second house is controlled by
the optimization algorithm because we
didn't tell the optimization algorithm
to find us alone norm solution somehow
implicitly finding a low norm solution
and in particular if we change
optimization algorithm we're gonna
change everything that's happening we're
going to change our complexity we're
going to change what what what an
inductive bias actually is and we
actually you can see it there's a blue
algorithm a red algorithm here both find
global Optima but one global Optima is
much better another intense in the sense
it generalizes better so again this is
an unfair thing to say that it's better
both of them are global optimum of the
optimization objective they do the
optimization algorithm in both cases did
exactly what it's supposed to but one of
them somehow found a better global
Optima that's better in some mysterious
quantity in particular generalization
that we did not actually tell the
optimization algorithm you can see this
another blogger and and read the
algorithm across the board many
optimization algorithms that optimize
this exact same objective but some of
them return global minima that are
I think Leon also alluded Etten's talked
before which means that really we're
talking about training deep networks
maybe what's more important is not the
model class but what's more important is
how we actually perform this
optimization we change how we perform
the optimization it completely changes
what are what really our learning
algorithm is ok so the way we should
really understand deep learning is not
that we have some model test and we're
searching in that model class and
finding an optimum but really what's a
optima of the training objective but
it's really what's up what's important
is how we're is how we're searching in
that space because roughly speaking
what's going on is that I search in a
space using some local some geometry and
I'm gonna find a solution that's cool
maybe close in some sense to this where
I started under that geometry but if I
change my geometry I'm gonna find a
different local a different global
optimum and so these are two different
trajectories of optimization I'm gonna
get two different global Optima here I
mean so in particular the models we're
looking at are highly over paralyzed
models so there are tons of global
Optima the way you should roughly think
of this is the global Optima are the
oceans okay and then and we're gonna
find we're gonna optimize and we're
gonna find that we're gonna start on
some hill and we will but eventually
gonna find a global off nor our training
objective so we're gonna find a point at
sea level but which point we're not
gonna go to the middle of the ocean
we're gonna go to a beach and which
Beach are going to go to if we start
optimizing here we're probably gonna get
is actually is Lake Washington at sea
level I'm not even sure
okay we're probably going to get to
either Puget Sound or Lake Washington if
we start optimizing in Boston we're
gonna get to that lactic and the
question is what happens you start
optimizing in Chicago I mean so if you
can go down from you can optimize from
Chicago and go down and get either to
Atlantic or the Gulf of Mexico or or to
the st. Lawrence and the thing is that
all of these things where are you going
to go is going to depend on you which
direction is your initiation algorithm
likes to go to and the thing is in very
high dimensions all the places are kind
of like Chicago in the sense that you
can get lots of places just by changing
your geometry okay and so the key here
in order to understand what all these
what actually happens in deep learning
we have to understand where are the
places these optimization algorithms are
going to go to and that's when I
what's going to give us all the
inductive bias and we'll get back to
this a bit later but an important thing
here is I would argue even more so that
the in fact the model class were
optimizing is so unimportant it's just
all functions okay so we know that with
large enough neural net so we can really
approximate those functions and I would
roughly argue that we are actually in
that regime we're optimizing over
networks at least we want to try to
optimize over networks are so rich they
can capture all functions so the model
class itself is not important at all
what's important is only how we search
inside it so how isn't searching inside
that's this model class can really give
these viruses and so the simplest
example to give it's just an under
specified linear regression model okay
so there are many optimum for this
problem many W such as that have zero
error here but if I use gradient descent
to optimize it the W that I'm going to
get to is not just going to be any
optimum any global optimum it's going to
be the minimum Euclidian norm global
optimum okay so note that I did not
specify the objective function here it
does not specify the ecclesia norm if
the Euclidean norm is only specified
implicitly by the choice of optimization
I mean I chose to optimize it using
gradient descent okay and now we can
kind of decouple this we understand the
geometry of the optimization how the
optimization gets us to not just any
solution but a minimum Euclidean norm
solution if the occluding arm the
cleanroom becomes our inductive bias if
that is a good inductive bias well good
good generalization properties by
changing the optimization algorithm
we're going to get to a different
solution so for example if instead of
grading the center you optimize with
mirror the center with respect to some
potential function or natural gradient
with respect to the geometry generated
website then at least with the small
enough step size infinitesimal
step size is what I'm gonna get now is
not to the minimum euclidian our
solution but the minimum size solution
whatever site is and getting a concealed
link here between the geometry of the
optimization in and where the what the
inductive bias becomes now instead of
having a model-based nucleating norm
teams of learning my my learning
actually becomes learning in terms of
this potential function okay so this is
with the squared loss logistic square
loss linear regression we also see a
similar thing with logistic regression
so take
logistic regression on separable data
okay so if you have if you have
separable data right linearly separable
data and you train a logistic regression
model in it so it's gonna find a way of
separating the data but there are many
ways of separating this data okay so if
you train your logistic regression model
with gradient descent what you're gonna
get the gradient descent is going to
converge not to just any separator but
it's going to converge exactly to the
hard margin SVM separator the separated
maximizes the Euclidean margin for the
data and again our opportunity our
objective function here is just logistic
regression and does not include the
hinge loss this is not part of it the
Euclidean norm is not part of it
hey the fact that we're getting a large
margin comes from the choice or
optimization algorithm yeah we change
our optimization algorithm and again
hard margin SVM solution in many cases
is a good thing to get to but if we
change our optimization algorithm if we
optimize the exact same model in
logistic regression but instead of using
gradient descent using coordinate
descent also a perfectly reasonable
optimization algorithm then what we're
gonna get to now is not the hard margin
SVM solution but actually the max L 1
margin solution and so we get a
different inductive bias and you'll
probably call these two things
completely different opportunity
learning algorithms with very different
learning properties very different
generalization properties okay again the
only thing that distinguish the
sometimes this will generalize well the
only thing that that distinguishes
between them is not your model just
linear models or your objective function
just logistic regression the only thing
that the street distinguish within them
is the optimization algorithm that used
in maybe a more interesting example is
from matrix factorization so if I solve
something like a matrix completion
problem and I do gradient descent so I'm
gonna solve a matrix completion problem
with greenies in just under metrics and
this doesn't make any sense
instead what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
write the metrics as u times V and I'm
do graining is sent on U and V okay but
U and V are still specifies all possible
matrices and just by and now it's my
optimization I just changed my
optimization algorithm I'm gonna do
gradient descent on univee and I'm gonna
get to zero solution and you can always
find a matrix that has zero
our metrics completion problem but it's
not gonna be just any solution it's
going to be the solution that minimizes
the trace number the nuclear norm and
again minimizing the nuclear norm is
actually a very good inductive bias in
many cases and can lead to learning okay
so to summarize the recap
did anybody understand anything okay
okay so to summarize the recap what we
talked about is here is that how the
geometry of the optimization argument
changes things I can go from if they go
from gradient descent according to
descent I can really change what I'm
getting to okay
but here we started seeing something
different because we're still talking
about gradient descent but what we
change here is actually the parameter
ization and and that also really has an
effect in the geometry if what's going
on so this was again from the metrics
completion so I want to know two things
here one is the change of geometry this
really we got a really rich inductive
bias you know meaning of nuclear norm by
changing the the parameter ization
in the second is it goes back if you
remember they talked about the oceans I
said that I'm optimizing my model crest
is really all possible models then also
here my model class is all everything in
this case all matrices right I'm solving
a metrics completion problem and my
model class is all matrices that's a
really stupid model class for metrics
completion and that doesn't you know
just includes everything and doesn't
give me any inductive bias all the
inductive bias is coming from the
optimization through the choice of
geometry another example in which we can
see it which maybe some of you have seen
and if not I think maybe Surya will talk
about tomorrow yes maybe yeah
is yeah so another thing with they were
going back to these reruns with TV
reruns you know there's sometimes out of
order so these talks are also bit out of
order we switched there's the left hand
switch so suriya's talked with whose
which is tomorrow should logically come
before this one so you should put this
on your stack and pop it back tomorrow
okay so if we're looking at training a
linear convolutional network there were
two linear convolutional network it's a
neural net with conversion of layers but
with linear activations okay so what's
the neural net with linear activations
it's a really stupid object because at
the end of the day just
apparent
as a linear mapping from input output so
why do I have these linear these
convolution layers they shouldn't do
anything I'm just learned training a
linear model okay so this is just a
complex over characterization for linear
models but and remember that if I took
gratings sent on the linear model what
I'm going to get is something like my
max margin and it turns out that if I do
it with with logistic loss it turns out
that if I do grating sent on this
strange parameterization then suddenly
something very rich comes out of it what
I get is I'm gonna minimize I'm gonna
get sparsity in the frequency domain so
with one convolution layer what I
minimize is the l1 of the Fourier
transform of the of my model I'm a
linear model and with deeper layers I'm
gonna minima implicitly roughly
implicitly minimize the bridge penalty
the LP bridge penalty first off like
with ten layers I'm going to minimize
the 0.2 quasi norm or whatever code for
on the frequency domain so with deeper
and deeper convolutional networks just
by changing this parameterization I'm
really getting here very rich inductive
bias so again we see the same phenomena
I'm optimizing over everything so for my
model classes everything what is
everything here everything here is all
linear models that's no we're live in
the linear world that's all we care
about the only thing I'm changing is the
parameter ization and I'm going
parameter izing it in some strange way
using convolutional in your networks and
I'm getting very rich inductive bias I'm
getting sparsely in the frequency domain
okay so so far I'm talk to you that
everything is mattresses or everything
is all linear models we can also talk
about everything being all functions
okay at least all univariate functions
so now consider learning a univariate
function using single layer relative
networks so now we're really talking so
with a single area network with
sufficiently large size and think of it
as infinite size I can represent any
function from R to R okay okay so what
happens if I actually train this network
with gradient descent or at least in
this case during gradient wouldwe DK it
turns out that what that happens now is
that just by doing this reporters
I'm in putting an inductive bias which
corresponds to the at the integral of
the absolute value of the second
derivative of the function so some kind
of a second-order total variation or
smoothness constraint again this doesn't
come this integral that absolute value
of the second derivative I did not
specify it explicitly all I said is I'm
gonna parent rise on all possible
functions using infinite with
RealNetworks okay by doing that and
considering that parameterization I'm
implicitly inducing this extremely rich
inductive bias so the the thesis I'm
trying to promote here is it really what
happens in neural networks it's not that
I put in a slight at the beginning that
all the architecture is not important
it's not that the architecture is not
important the architecture is very
important the model class defined by the
architecture is not important the model
class defined architecture is all
functions that's not important hey why
is the architecture important because I
have my parameters here this is relates
very much to my own stock in the
optimization maybe puts a very simple
inductive type of inductive bias on on
these parameters okay some kind of like
simple spherical ish inductive bias but
the permit the choice of parameters
ation the architecture specifies a
choice of parameter ization which means
the mappings from these parameters to
the function space and after all what I
care about is the function space okay
whether it's linear functions or all
functions and what we saw is that by
specific choices of parameter ization
specific choices of architecture what I
what gets induced in the function space
can be extremely rich and interesting
inductive biases like this second-order
total variation or sparsity in a
frequency domain or or trace norm I mean
okay so so this is okay so now let's try
to see if we can get I mean if
understand this may be more generally
not being in these concrete examples so
we can in fact do that let's focus at
least on on linear model so models are
sorry
okay sorry not focusing on your article
back okay so let's try to understand
that generally so no in order to do that
well since I'm saying that everything
here is about the parameter ization
architecture we can think of this
function capital f is the function that
map's from our parameters to our
function to our model okay so in other
words you can think of if if I have a
I'm going to use little F to denote to
map from a model and inputs to the
output of the model in those inputs in
capital F maps from W to the function
implemented by that W okay so for linear
models for example I have that fw x is
some linear function determined by a by
W times X and my model function is a
mapping from W to that linear function
so for confidence for example it takes
my weights and outputs the linear
transformation given by that model so
what we can say is at least for D
homogeneous functions model so what's
the homogeneous functions so do modulus
means that if I multiply all the weights
by some constant and the output gets
multiplied by that constant the power of
D so you should think of Diaz roughly
the depth of the net of the model and so
one homogeneous linear models two
homogeneous things like matrix
factorization or two layer networks and
D homogeneous and generalize things with
depth D ok so at least for homogeneous
networks for any order then in fact what
we saw before is roughly correct mean so
we can say that the inductive bias in
the in the parameter space is very very
simple the inductive bias in the
parameter space is just given by
minimizing the Euclidian norm so this is
if I do should say this is the inductive
bias of doing gradient descent on
logistic regression with a deal modulus
parameterization is just given by
minimum Euclidian norm in that
parameters but in in the parameter space
and then the Prem the inductive bias
induced into a function space then is
just simply given by mapping this
inductive bias in parameter space to
function space so for each function that
kind of complexity cost of that function
is the cheapest way to represent a
cheapest in terms of Euclidian norm
in that parameter ization okay so this
suggests that actually when I started by
saying that you know the important of
geometry maybe it's not maybe all this
geometry of optimization I don't really
this emphasis an optimization algorithm
is really unfounded because maybe all
this implicit organization really all
boils down to just l2 in cram dress the
importance of the mapping so this would
be I don't know maybe good news and
maybe bad news for us because that means
means that you know several you know the
past two years of research of trying to
understand this connections in
optimization the optimization algorithm
inductive bias you know maybe it all
boils down just to mapping the Euclidean
norm in the parameter space to what's
going on in function space and we did
see this is exactly happening both
metrics recur ization and for this
linear convolutional networks in for
these general homogeneous models and so
is this the case so there is some
evidence here that it is there's also
some evidence is what's going on this is
more complex so one thing is do these
conditions especially the homogeneity
actually hold do we actually is it
really the the many of the models were
looking at that succeed are not
necessarily of modulus it's very
possible that there or we know that
there are more complex things are going
on more than that there's some
subtleties in going from what we can
guarantee here is only not really
minimizing the parameters the inclusion
of the parameters but only converging to
first order sick stationary points here
in the transition between first are
stationary points in parameter space to
even local optima in the function space
is actually not at all direct I mean
there many first started stationary
points here that do not map to local
minimum parameter space and recently
there's some evidence that for with
squared loss or our results are for the
X plus or logistic loss and there's some
evidence from Sanjeev Aurora's group did
for the squared loss this does not
happen yeah so that
a minimum that for doing gradient
descent on even homogeneous functions
particularly deep metrics factorizations
does not correspond to minimizing the
the deleting or in parameter space in
this suggested maybe also for the X plus
the connection does exist but only it
does some Tata climate of the
optimization where your optimized got
extremely small error and for any
reasonably small error some more
interesting things are going on here so
this is one way how much time do I have
I'm just about to if okay I should start
five minutes oh okay hey went through
this a bit too slowly okay so we'll soon
get to the main meteor okay so this
suggests that's fine
so this is also a very important point
for this no no seven minutes is fine
eight okay so this suggests that that
that really there's something more going
on here and then we'll soon at the end
of those eight minutes see maybe some
more evidence that what's going on here
is maybe more complex than just
minimizing the de Noren parameter space
but especially after maladies talk when
I'm talking about the implicit
organization where the optimization goes
to you might be thinking if all this
boils down to just looking at the in the
kernel regime some of these results I
guess actually mud whereas maybe he was
here yes okay I guess you didn't
actually explicitly mention there okay
so you tricked me
but there are many recent results it
suggests that look at how a neural net
or study how neural networks operate in
terms of the tangent kernel I mean in
those result by first reading them kind
of again is something that should make
you doubt whether all this we can
actually get all these induct rich
inductive biases so let me just recap so
what do we mean when we talk about the
kernel regime so for any model and we
can always locally look at a linear
approximation of that model I mean so
once I look at a linear approximation of
a model it's a linear model and it can
capture it with a kernel okay then this
is an if the kernel that captures the
local behavior the tangent
behavior around some initial model W
mean and there have been and if we
there's been some results that study
neural networks just in that Colonel
regime when they this linear
approximation actually captures what's
going on and show that actually you can
get zero training error in the kernel
regime and which suggests that you never
leave the kernel regime but if you never
leave the kernel regime all your
training behaves as if it's a kernel and
then we know exactly what the inductive
bias would be it would just be the
minimum kernel norm for squared loss or
max margin hard-hard margin SVM with
that kernel in the case of logistic loss
but that that view seems to kind of be
very different from what we saw before
because what we saw before is all kinds
of rich behaviors that cannot be
captured by kernels okay so in
particular if we focus even on okay
sorry
we've got rich behaviors that cannot be
captured by kernels so things like the
trace norm or this second-order total
variations are things that are
inherently not kernels there's no kernel
that will give you that inductive bias
so what's going on here
so it seems that what plays a crucial
role is the scale of initialization this
was pointed out by cheese Otten buck in
the recent paper which mentioned already
several times
so let's look stick to these D
homogeneous models and we'll look at a
deal Martinus model now we're looking
infinitesimal step size so look at the
behavior of gradient flow rather than
gradient descent and we'll initialize to
the model with some scale alpha so alpha
is gonna be the scale at which we
initialize the model and what then will
let it evolve and what we're interested
is when we'll actually where will this
grading flow converge to so generally
converging to 0 our solution we're not
gonna be concerned here about conditions
forgets your error let's trust me that
will always get to your training error
but the question is which zero training
error solution are we going to get to
and and so and the question is will this
behave like a kernel okay like a floor
they get from the kernel in what cheese
at and buck shown is at least 4 squared
loss if I take this initialization to
infinity for any model
they take the initialization to infinity
if I'm there at least afaik in gets your
air then for throughout the entire
training I will behave the the
trajectory of training will behave like
a kernel the kernel in other words a
very muddy disgust that the kernel is
not gonna the tangent kernel is not
gonna change through training which
means that I'm what I'm actually doing
is just changing a training a kernel
model and I get very kind of maybe
boring
inductive bias what I get is just the
minimum the minimum kernel norm and so I
can do anything that I cannot do in
kernels okay but we saw before that we
actually do get things that you cannot
do in kernels and something crucial that
I glossed over before is that this would
squared loss to get these rich behaviors
like for example get the minimum traced
arm solution we have to get the
initialization to zero so it seems that
the crucial thing here is how do we
initialize when you initialize very
large we get a kernel behavior and you
get to get this really leverage the
depth and get the rich behavior we have
to put the initialization to zero okay
okay so in order to understand this very
exactly we consider the simplest
possible model which exhibits this kind
of behavior and this is again a linear
model but with a very strange
parameterization so linear model with
the two homogeneous parameter ization so
to live to you can think of it as a
simple two layer neural network great
that it's just a linear model but each
coefficient we parameterize by is the
square of our parameters and we include
here actually two parameters for each
coordinate each Corinne is given by the
square root of the positive part minus
the square of negative part and this is
for two reasons one so that we can
actually get all linear predictors we
can get both negative and positive
coefficients and the second is so that
we initially we can initialize in a way
that has very large magnitude in
parameter space but it's still zero
initialization in function space and
okay so if we initialize all of these
weights to want to some scaling of to
alpha to the same alphas getting alpha
times all ones then we can make alpha
very large but energy but this
corresponds to a linear predictor which
is this is zero predictor and and let's
and what we're going to look at is
wedding
device do we get so initialized to alpha
and I'm going to look at better else
insanity is going to be the linear
predictor that I get at the end of
training it's going to be a zero error
zero training are predicted but which
the our training error predictor so
again she's at and buck tell me that
when alpha goes to infinity I mean going
to get the minimum the korean regime you
can work out the tangent
Christianisation here it turns out to be
just a scaling of the standard Euclidean
norm and so I get the minimum l 2-norm
solution but there's a special case of
some results we saw before in metrics
vectorization we know that if alpha goes
to zero we get a very different
inductive bias so what we get is the
minimum l1 arm solution so just changing
the the scale initialization gets us
completely different inductive biases
here so it's the same model and the only
thing i change the scale initialization
i mean
moreover we can actually understand
exactly this transition so you can work
out ER analytically the the inductive
bias that you get for any finite
initialization alpha okay and this is
given by this penalty so again you get
you definitely this your error solution
you're always so gonna solve your linear
system you're going to get the zero
solution it minimizes this hyper entropy
func penalty with scale alpha what this
means is that I have the function Q
which is given here explicitly but don't
look at this I'm gonna show you a plot
very soon scaled by alpha so how does
this function look like I mean it's very
nice they can write it analytically what
is important is this function looks like
this
okay so around zero it's called it's
quadratic in the way from 0 it's
basically linear okay so now let's look
at the scale of initialization yes the
square root will be is larger
what happens the square root when B is
larger than 2 that's an excellent
question can be a beacon I'm sorry
okay that's a plus in here right no no
yeah sorry yeah yeah because it's a plus
here oh so it's a plus sorry maybe it's
a bus also here no sorry that should be
a plus sorry that should be a plus so
it's always fine okay so what you're
still not okay I mean this is okay so
wait wait no it should be should be B I
know it's fine it's a it's a it's a plus
this emergency it's fine it's fine it's
a plus
nothing special for vehicles - okay it's
just a plus okay so so what happens here
is that when initialized with alpha goes
to infinity that means a scale my
coefficients are it's zero just for the
purpose of calculating this and what's
important is the behavior of the
destroyer eliezer around here and they
have essentially an l2 regulator when it
initialize with alpha goes to zero okay
then what's happening is only B if
you're here and they get l1 rigorous
ation but any value in between I'm gonna
get some interpolation of l1 and l2 our
ization yeah so so so I get your
interpolation of l1 and l2 and when you
talk just about l1 l2 maybe that doesn't
seem very special but remember that l1
versus l2 can make a huge difference in
terms of generalization so if what we're
facing is this part is a sparse problem
so as far as linear regression problem
so I get generated the truth actually
behaves according to a sparse model if
I'm at a large alpha I mean meaning
they're minimizing effectively
minimizing the l2 norm I'm not gonna get
any learning okay so this is here what I
plotted here is actually the this is the
generalization or the population error
of training in order to learn I need to
initialize alpha to be very very small
and so in other words what we're seeing
here this is the kernel regime over here
in the kernel regime we're not gonna get
any learning because the kernel here is
not actually doesn't provide any useful
inductive bias to get good inductive
bias you want to get to get this rich
inductive bias that leverages the depth
of the network we need to initialize
with alpha that's small in order to
behave like more like an L
yeah and we see transition here from a
small the the rich regime that takes
advantage of the depth to of the kernel
regime now we have to balance this with
another consideration which is when
alpha is very very small it's very hard
to optimize because remember that we're
gonna initialize its scale alpha zero is
a saddle point
so initially it's a very very small
alpha that means we're starting to
optimize very close to a saddle point I
mean so here it's easy to optimize this
is where all noddy's result about
current optimization live and it tells
it's very easy to optimize this very
quickly and we're gonna get to
government very well so in terms of
optimization we want to be here in terms
of learning we want to be here but at
the heart optimization becomes very very
hard so which I'll far you gonna choose
the offer you gonna choose is going to
be just at the edge of the rich resume
okay so the regime we want to be here is
not actually the fully the regime but
actually this transition between the
rich regime in the kernel issue okay
another way to see it is as follows so
let's look at this pie it seems far as
regression problem when you have more
and more and more and more data okay and
which outfit we want to use we want to
use the alpha to make optimization the
easiest so you want to use the largest
possible alpha that would still allow us
to learn okay if we're right on the
information threshold we really need to
use a very very small alpha in order to
get the right inductive bias an
optimization will be very very difficult
is we have more and more samples we can
very quickly allow ourselves to use a
much larger alpha and now over here we
can actually also do the optimization I
mean this is just hand waving but
reasonably effective efficient lee alpha
is a reasonable value we start away from
the saddle point when we can still
optimize okay I promised you a
relationship to okay so now I promised
you a relationship 0 minutes fine
perfect a relationship to explicitly
realization and you can ask whether we
can actually understand all this just in
terms of again minimizing l2 in in the
parameter space so you can say well what
does the initialization correspond to I
say that roughly speaking what I look at
is distance from initialization also for
at least square problems you don't
actually minimize the occluding norm you
clearly this is too initialization so
let's define the linear aggressor which
is your lower or linear solution here
the minimum the zero error solution
which is closest in Euclidean distance
to the vector of all alphas okay so this
would be the the direct regulation
version of initializing to alpha and
then doing gradient descent and we can
ask are these two the same thing so it
turns out that also here we can write
the solution as minimizing some implicit
regulators to friends implicit regulator
and they can write down exactly what the
simplicity regularizer in this implicit
regularizer
turns out to be the solution of this
quadric equation okay that's the exact
quadric equation it's not so important
what's important what you're gonna check
that it's correct it's important to
Andrea okay
what's important is riveted before we
add this transcendental function we were
involving involving a hyperbolic sine
that's very different the solution to
our trick was just algebraic okay so I
can plot here both of them in fact
they're very different in particular a
solution to a quartic equation is just a
rational function which means that it
goes if I ask how quickly when alpha
goes to zero am I gonna get l1 that's
gonna be polynomially fast as opposed to
the this Q function what I get from the
plist organization dukedom the
optimization because of the hyperbolic
sine there then alpha has to be
exponentially small in order to
approximate the l1 arm so there's a very
fundamental difference here between the
explicit rigorous a shin and the
implicit explicit organization I get by
saying I want to be close to
initialization and the implicit
organization I get very great indecent
okay okay I have to finish here to tell
you that all these things carry over
also to the metrics case although maybe
less rigorously in the metrics case here
also you can talk about the set the
problem in the same way talk about the
kernel regime in the rich regime the
rich regime here is minimum traced norm
and the kernel zoom here is really lazy
it's just says completely observed
entries and don't touch anything else
okay and as you move between them we can
see also what happens maybe sir is going
to talk about that tomorrow but let me
just conclude here and again I think
that the the the important thing in I
agree with some of the sentiments that
Leon said before did the important thing
in understanding deep learning is really
not the model class but the optimization
where there's optimization
it's not enough for the optimization to
be easy we actually want optimization
not to be too easy so it also gets us to
two interesting rich models okay in
order to do that we have to apparently
understand both the optimization of the
geometry of the optimization itself an
inductive bias of the optimization it's
not enough to just rely on explicitly
realization it seems to me that the main
force actually plays this implicit
organization of the optimization longer
than not explicitly realization and
understand very carefully the the
parameters Asians used in the royalty
they play okay thank you
[Applause]
you